[موسيقى]
تدور الارض حول الشمس في مدار بيضاوي مره
واحده في كل سنه ولهذا في المسافه بينهما
تتغير على مدار ساعه بالزياده او النقصان
في الشتاء تتناقص وفي الصيف تتزايد فاقرب
مسافه بينهما تسمى نقطه الحظير وتكون في
عز الشتاء كحالي ايامنا هذه وابعد مسافه
بينهما تكون في عز الجيل وتسمى نقطه الاوج
وفي حاله الاعتدال الربيع والخليفي تكون
وسطيه في مسافتها اما ان تكون وسطيا في
حياتك لا تكن سكارا فتاكلك الناس ولا حنضل
فيورما
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وخلال هذا الاسبوع ستكون الارض في اقرب
نقطه لها من الشمس واحب فيكم ان البعد
والقرب ليس اساسا في الحراره فهو نسبي
فاقرب مسافه 147 وابعد مسافه 153 مليون
كيلو متر فالذي يعتمد او يتحكم في الحراره
هو زاويه سقوط شعاع الشمس ففي الصيف تكون
عموديه وفي الشتاء تكون مائله فالعموديه
تجمع الحراره والميلان يشتت الحراره
والشمس في كبد السماء مريضه والارض واقفه
تكاد تمور ما كنت احسب قبل دفنك في الثرى
ان الكواكب في الترابي
تغرو
[موسيقى]